[Musique]
la tempête ANK se poursuit Météo France
recommande de rester attentif aux
dangers éventuels provoqués par les
intempéries les Yvelines ont été placé
en vigilance jaune pour les vents et les
orages des rafales devrai souffler à
plus de 80 kmh et la foudre pourrait
frapper entre midi et 21h en fin de
matinée les Pompi éelinois n'avait pas
noté de pic de sortie ces conditions ont
débuté hier la mairie de Versailles
avait choisi de fermer ses parcs et ses
jardins 12 jeunes catholiques issus des
quartiers populaires des ivelines du
valdoise et de saintsint vont rencontrer
le pape François parti pour Rome depuis
hier ils s'en tiendront demain avec le
représentant de l'Église chrétienne
parmi eux quatre trapistes une rencontre
provoquée par la mort de naë à nantherre
en juin 2023 ces jeunes croyants ont
pour ambition de montrer une image plus
solidaire des quartiers populaires j 205
avant le lancement des jeux olympique et
paralympique 2024 l'abélisé terre de
jeux Saint-Quentin en yeline accueillera
5 épreuves du 28 juillet au 11 août et
du 28 août au 8 septembre cyclisme sur
piste VTT golf BMX Race et paracyclisme
sur piste à l'occasion de ce début
d'année Sky entre en jeu pour ne rien
rater vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations relatives aux épreuves sur
le site Sky et les jeux et si vous
souhaitez également devenir bénévole sur
l'événement vous avez jusqu'au 15
janvier pour vous inscrire sur le
site